when you two decided okay you're gonna
you're gonna sleep in here tonight was
it like did she come up to you and go
hey you know you liked sleeping on the
couch or do you wanna you want to come
in or were you like hey maybe tonight I
know we got we we actually was just a
night where that we had had like she was
having like a zoom like happy hour thing
with her family so you know I started
drinking in the background when the kids
went to sleep and then I just kind of
woke I was just drunk and just we will
just woke up in the room together so
yeah we get yelled at uh-huh what I mean
what do you mean trouble
oh this is what he was talking about oh
are you did you get in trouble hello
yeah good things she didn't like these
did the drunk story oh maybe just say
yes say yes or no like what just she
didn't know she need to talk yes I was
just talking about how great things have
been going yeah he's happy
what no more listening no no you know
what Chris is doing right now Jim and
I'm gonna whisper in case there's any
Christmas right now he's going like oh
[ __ ] this was the other part of it okay
that's a [ __ ] no chicks gonna talk to me
like that oh how great is this okay I do
insane no it's not that show what show
Jim what do you think it is we've all
been there I can't even you know me
[ __ ] women in my life mad at things
I've said on the radio I mean
it's just my wife would get furious with
me furious with me I'd come home and be
like what and it was the exact same
conversation - you'd never expect it
you'd never know it was coming
and then right my wife would be like I
heard something on the air and you'd be
like yeah yeah I thought it was all good
and she's like no cause you said that
you're like what they and you and you're
like I thought I thought I was being
cool and it turns out people take things
differently but happens to the best of
us what can you do what I should
probably go yeah yeah what can you do
your story you saying nice stories and
then things go haywire sometimes so you
know it happens to the best of us all
right Bubba
well it's good to talk to you and Jim
and I are gonna have a conversation
right now as to which show did she think
that we were that she know if she knows
which show Chris is just such a smart
guy is covering for he's gonna course
it's this show exactly she hates us how
can people you guys yeah a Kristy comedy
is my Instagram Kristy comedy calm at
history hyenas on Instagram and that's
the history in his podcast but the
morning show and all like the other
content is patreon.com slash Bay Ridge
Boys all right party good thank you nice
voice we appreciate it buddy all right
all right talk to you later